hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a game called
constellation now this game is different
than anything i've ever seen before and
i mean that quite literally
because all you do is type things like
dog or cat
or cow
traffic cone guitar
skull skeleton
man woman women
ooh men cows
cones ah
well hi okay so i don't know if there's
an objective to this game
but uh i've only i only just did a few
things
and apparently there's tons and tons of
commands in this game
and i have no idea what they are so i'm
gonna
find out here we go a butt nope
oh sexy boobs nope
god damn it a man can dream um
happy what
what oh it just saturated everything
all right okay stuff
duck oh ducks ducks
ducks ducks ducks nope ducks
ducks ducks ducks ducks
ducks
that ain't ducks nope ducks
sun oh sons
many suns lots of suns
ah a hundred sun oh a hundred sons
sun ah star
ah oh no oh i goofed it
i goofed it okay wait ah star
okay all right universe
galaxy
oh what the hell
what the hell oh
that's awesome that's so cool so uh
that's a thing what the hell yo
cell molecule
adam
wow okay um yeah
yeah about that
okay cows
hi guys planet-sized cows in the galaxy
dogs cats all right cool all right
everything is right in the universe when
uh giant cat dog and cows
orbit the galaxy i think we all know
this a safe place
all right um clear
oh good good good good good good oh
a [ __ ] whoa oh
whoa cows cows on
the cows on the beach okay i got cows on
the beach
my dream has come true happy ah
i can't see [ __ ] phone
phones normal oh
whoa what the hell oh
that's weird forest oh
lake
sky ah that's sky
all right whatever you say skye
all right okay oh it changes the sky
oh god no devil
well i'm in hell okay wait
i know that skybox wait a minute isn't
that the sky box from the
from doom that is legitimately isn't
that
am i crazy that's that looks like it's
from doom i i might be crazy
doom uh oh no now then
now that that is the skybox from doom
i didn't know that game
i got a score
[Music]
okay youtube nope computer
ah please dummy there's ah there we have
it
internet oh
ah ooh 3d
it's darkiplier everybody run away okay
anyway
[Music]
what the hell i just typed life okay all
all right fruits
oh that's that's a thing of beauty oh
that is oh
that is pretty okay wait
there's something that's missing here
cows
[Music]
[Laughter]
lose okay what else do we have
does that oh
whoa alrighty then
oh okay see ya oh okay bye
oh ah
[Music]
oh
all right well there you have it okay
there's got to be more words that i can
come up with right
okay ah potato
tomato ah ardvark
aardvark l
a fan tree no
foam camera
what oh it's a filter oh
um ah instagram
ah constellation
oh i already got that ah light
light
make this cow really bright
[Music]
that's a breakout happy
almost there
ah there we go
nice okay um
what what
sure okay what does matrix do
oh it arranges them in a matrix oh
can i go
ah oh
now this this is the hd cow action i was
looking for
oh that's nice oh that's nice we need
one more cow
okay two two more okay
um steam engine ah
steve jobs lady
no new grounds
oh
happy what else we got marsh
oh is that a marsh is it really a mar uh
it's a marsh
i can tell by the one marsh
whoa oh
whoa cool
beneath what
where oh well what oh
all right okay okay all right weird
okay
ah
i don't like that okay that's not good
utah what what
what is that it's a darkiplier mug
teapot
i'm in utah apparently what the hell
where's he utah why is you two why is
utah above our hurricane
what that doesn't make any sense
okey-dokey then
hourglasses okay skye
tubes little tubes
ah oh god oh god
penguins oh penguins yeah normal
oh why utah why
ohio texas
al fornae oh
[Music]
oklahoma nevada
arizona ah
lovely canada
you're open apocalypse
nuke oh the light asses
[Music]
i still don't get this that doesn't make
any sense
sepia explode
donut cinema
the oh god i'm gonna cross my eyes on
this one
wait hang on turn on the 3d
it works oh my god it works i can't
believe it works
holy [ __ ] that works what the [ __ ] hey
it works it works if you cross your eyes
it works
loose [ __ ] cow 3d
vr baby oh that's a nice cow
it's coming right at me oh it's like i
can touch it
oh geez what else we got palm trees
ah cool
ah
why are they so big
offices ah
oh ah it ruined it what did i do
ah god damn it okay office
nope
what turtle
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
okay vr
3d cow
nice okay so that's constellation
i'm i'm willing to bet that there's tons
more
commands in here and you can get them by
randomly generating them i guess but i
bet there's some hidden ones in here
so i'll leave a link to this game in the
description below it's really fun
it's just a very simple very different
game but
it is fun so let me know if you guys
find any cool
and interesting secret things in there
because
again i'm willing to bet that they're
hiding a ton so thank you everybody so
much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below and as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye